مشهد رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي وهو يجلس
صعوبه في تغريد رئيس الاركان الجديد رتبته
العسكريه ويضعها مقلوبه قد تكون مصادفه
لكنها لم تخلو من مفارقه رمزيه فالجينرال
هيرسياليفي ليس خيار تنياه المفضل لانه من
تعيينه وزير الدفاع السابق غانس في اخر
ايام الحكومه الانتقاليه في ما اراد
نتنياهو مستشاره العسكري السابق اللواء
يلتمر
حول الملك الايراني
الا انه ربما مستبعدا هناك اجماع بين
المستويين السياسي والعسكري حول الملف
الايراني يقول محللون اسرائيلون ايضا انه
على الرغم من انني تنياهو ليس مغامرا
عسكريا عاده فانه بات يرى نفسه من منظور
تاريخي كمن سينهي المشروع النوي الايراني
ويستهدف المنشات ويستذكرون عام 2012 حين
قرر ذلك فعليا لكن معارضه رئيس الاركان في
حينه بين جانس والمؤسسه الامنيه منعت
التنفيذه لهذا قد لا يكون مرتاحا لوجود
الذي عينه
[موسيقى]
الجيش والمصاد بالتعاون مع جهاز الشباك
سيقومون بما يلزم للرد بحرب ضد اعداءنا
نظام ايران مسؤول عن 90% من مشاكل المنطقه
ويهدد بتدمرنا الاعتقاد في اسرائيل لم
يتغير بان ايران تستطيع لا لا اسابيع
الانطلاق الى تخصيب يورانيوم بنسبه 90%
اللازمه لانتاج قنبله نوويه لكن التطوير
الراس الحربي والتسليح يحتاج اقل من عامين
ويبقى السؤال امام قائد جيشها الجديد متى
يشن هجوم عسكريه على ارضيه التقصيب ام عند
المرحله النهائيه قبل التسليح التهديدات
والتدريبات الاسرائيليه العلنيه على توجيه
ضربه لايران وفقه مراقبين قد تحتمل
تفسيرين متناقدين فقد تكون لتهيئه راي
عاميه لضربه اسرائيليه مستقله للمنشات او
العكس اي محاوله ردى ايران عن الهروله
تجاه القنبله النوويه منعا لهجوم اسرائيلي
غير جاهز بعد زياده حلبي العربيه القدس
الغربيه